it will be Canadian wedding et Canada
got all the exclusive details for Keshia
chante and Ray Emery summer weddings the
I Do's will be exchanged in June in
front of family and friends
aka a star-studded guest lid ray is
who's the DJ what is the music and can I
invite every way so does that include
longtime friend Drake Keshia is being
coy on some of the details but she is
sharing secrets with her fans for me
like I like to keep my private life
private but at the same time exciting
moments that you know people are maybe
rooting you know for you like oh I can't
wait for you get married or I want to
see these pictures or what kind of dress
are you wearing you want it you want to
share things with people speaking of the
dress Keshia will walk down the aisle in
a $10,000 Zuhair Murad gown fresh off
the runway it's gorgeous
his last year in Chicago was the only
year I stopped working and I just
focused on him yeah happy to be the same
year they won the Stanley Cup
the singers scored a spot on season two
of hockey wives without Ray to show fans
a different side of her ray is extremely
private
it's like win games and no other
distractions and I totally respect that
and that's totally his process so that's
why he didn't want to be on the show you
pick a fight yeah you literally have to
wait for their day off we should always
strive to be the best versions of
ourselves what perfection isn't real and
I think it's important that you share
the ups and downs especially the Downs
because that's how people get through
things that's why I'm an artist that's
why I make music
he just had numerous chart-topping
singles but now after a six-year break
the Juno award-winning singer is making
a comeback and dropped a new EP unbound
one it's a passion project for me it's
where I'm very honest and now the 28
year old is ready to shed her good-girl
image and showcase the sexier side some
of the songs are a little uncomfortable
for people I'll be honest with you like
my dad like cringes listening to it and
I love that because you want to be edgy
you want to speak up I feel like this is
the first time that I'm able to really
give people exactly who I am and I'm
feeling really confident and comfortable
in it